come it on your IMDB you say that you
know you take a lot of time to put in
two roles maybe 12 hours or so a day
what type of preparation do you do for a
rule and what did you do to prepare for
your role as a brain look first of all
when when you when I receive is good I
am convinced that I don't know this
person and I have to learn to get to
know this is the most important and if
if the script or the character related
to an incident like September 11 you
have to learn about 111 you have to
watch again the footage on YouTube for
example to get the mood to see what
happened exactly what the people feel
what did they react what was the mood
during this it takes too much time and I
have maybe it's a it's a bad habit for
for my family that I have to have a
script everywhere at home one in the
reception on in my room one in the
bathroom and with a pencil that what if
I got an idea four o'clock in the
morning that I have to find the script
beside me to write it and I read the
script a lot and I keep it in my mind
and I eat my role a lot daily daily and
till I seen I see him coming after me
till I see myself this is not fair that
this is someone else
this is till I see his voice this is
very important his movements his whoa
it's not an easy job and this is why I'm
working and I love my profession I love
it and and and working not only on the
script you have to
go to the Germany or - it's really a
very tough profession and I had that
great director it was his he was the
biggest one in them they're appalled
Youssef Chahine the one who launched me
when I is when he sees me
I've had it Orem okay it used to be an
actor you have to fulfill your your
profession otherwise go and do something
else
what are those moments that make you
feel like you've had it and I'm tired
sometimes I'm tired I I feel so moments
and it's few moments and then it goes
otherwise I wouldn't I wouldn't stay for
20 years doing it so it's a it's a great
profession and I'm lucky to be an actor
you